I've used marijuana for the past five
years and find it to be probably the the
best drug you want to call it that in
the litany of drugs that I use as far as
the way I feel about having MS I
remember one gentleman was suffering
two weeks to live very dreary dark
wasn't eating gotten down too
they brought in
and it was unbelievable in about a half
an hour opened his eyes and said where's
the pizza if this were something that we
just discovered in the Amazon
you know everybody would be knocking
doors down to do clinical trials to
investigate its potential because it is
quite an amazing medicine
in the clinic here at San Francisco
General Hospital we had a volunteer Mary
Rathbun who was our volunteer of the
year for two years in a row she was an
older woman and she used to bring her
kids as she called our patients
marijuana brownies this was at a time
when we didn't have any effective
therapies for hiv/aids and many people
were dying of the so called wasting
syndrome I was in Amsterdam of all
places at the International AIDS
Conference and glancing at CNN Headline
News and I saw that Mary was being
arrested in Sonoma
for baking brownies for our patients and
when I arrived home there was a letter
directed to the director of research in
the AIDS program at San Francisco
General suggesting that a clinical trial
showing the benefits of medical
marijuana should come from brownie
Mary's institution as if she were our
Dean but you know I picked up the
gauntlet and decided well that's a good
idea I worked as a clinical consultant
for the elderly I have the course
revocation of geriatrics and also worked
for the past 25 years
thus helping his
and that's where my passion began I saw
people in their last days of their life
suffering a lot from
other types of symptoms
they usually had so many narcotic
analgesics that they were definitely not
even lucid and really
quality of life before they passed away
and so many people asked about marijuana
how they could get it so usually I had
to tell them as 15 years ago that 20
years ago that they need to talk with
their friends children or adolescents
and they could probably help them
unfortunately there was no way to find
out what it was or what type of cannabis
they were using but the results of using
cannabis were just dramatic my shake
because of the MS at which I had at that
time under notes to me because I hadn't
been diagnosed at that time but my eyes
were shaken and I but smoked marijuana
it slowed down my shaking I and I could
study and so I got through junior
college well enough to be accepted at
Texas A&M that the fact I played a
little football when I left Texas A&M
and got into the industry as an engineer
I quit smoking marijuana altogether I
was a coat and tie every day at work
came out here in about 1980 81 and began
designing offshore platforms when my
balance continued to get worse out here
in California and because my job
required that I climbed the Derrick's my
balance was a major issue safety was
through that scenario I was diagnosed
with MS at about 1980 to 81 1981
Cannabis the plant has a number of
active compounds called cannabinoids and
they belong to a family of 21 carbon
chemicals that all have biologic
activity we believe that they're about
70 or 80 different cannabinoids in
marijuana so what investigators found in
the 1970s and 80s was that we have
receptors in our body cb1 and cb2 that
complex with these cannabinoids from the
plants now why would we and all other
animal species mind you have these cb1
receptors it's not because we're meant
to smoke marijuana what we find out is
that we have our own circulating
cannabinoid chemicals in our body that
don't come from the plant they're
generally produced on demand and they
complex with the receptor and they cause
a biological action we're working on a
product now in a lollipop or lozenge
form that's high in Delta 8 THC instead
of Delta 9
and when we were extracting we came up
with that and said you know what is
Delta eight and we found that Delta 8
was about 50% as potent as THC so causes
less of the euphoria before it effects
but it's 200 times more potent in
helping with nausea vomiting so it's a
great product for our patients
undergoing chemotherapy
I think most of the interest now is on
another cannabinoid called cannabidiol
otherwise known as CBD this cannabinoid
seems to have really potent
anti-inflammatory and anti-panic tivity
without having a psychological effect or
without producing a high and as an
oncologist there's hardly a cancer
patient that I see for whom I don't
recommend cannabis because these are
patients especially those who are
undergoing chemotherapy who benefit from
anti nausea increased appetite we have
many many other anti-nausea drugs but
cannabis is the only drug that also
increases appetite and we know it
decreases pain again especially in
conjunction with opioids helps people
sleep better and it decreases depression
so those are five reasons that a cancer
patient might benefit from cannabis and
if I were not familiar with cannabis as
medicinal properties I would have to
prescribe five different medicines all
of which would have side effects
toxicity and cost I'm probably under the
care of all eight drugs right now
injections and oral tablets and and
they're all preventative that
you-you-you don't really feel the
effects but you ought to see the
downsides on the bottle the bottles will
scare you to death like I'm on one drug
for the multiple sclerosis for
spasticity it's called what is this
what's an int is battleship and part of
the problem with baclofen is that it
makes you tired it's kind of a downer so
then they gave me what is this debt
friend feta mean to counteract the
sleepiness of this
I'll see what we have here effexor this
antidepressant now I'm not sure where
they make the a and I depressed or not
that's a that's kind of a attitude that
and having MS is depressing but I can't
say one thing of all the drugs that I do
take the only one that really seems to
affect my day-to-day attitude and point
of view is marijuana when I worked in a
pharmacy if somebody called us that they
had overdose we would immediately call
911
the paramedics the good thing if we get
a call a person's over medicated with
cannabis we tell them to sit down drink
lots of water eat and those symptoms of
dizziness and out of control will
subside in a couple of hours so that's
that's the beauty cannabis it's much
safer you know I've been a doctor now
for 30-some years and the number of
patients that I've admitted to the
hospital with complications related to
marijuana use was exactly one when I was
an intern in 1978 somebody smoked
cannabis laced with PCP and had a
psychotic reaction the number of
patients I've admitted with
complications due to alcohol is enormous
so you know I yeah I think we need to
re-evaluate what we do in this country
and it's all politics and economics the
nose of the camel is already in the tent
and it's because of videos like this and
questions being asked about this drug
Hallett's utilize how it affects the
just they have 9 to 5 of my day
he's worked towards changing the
schedule of canvas inaudible schedule
one
schedule one obviously says there's no
additional value and
we all know doctors physicians
researchers pharmacists patients means
that there's incredible visual value